it's interesting that you talk about the
travel because when we talked to Morgan
Spurlock about the comic-con dog he was
saying he was kind of going on the road
to do this sort of tour and I asked him
what do you do for Morgan time because
you're going to be you know your jet lag
and you're going to different places and
I'm sure that the you know constant
barrage of things going on maybe wears
on you so what do you do to recharge so
that your fresh I try and find four
hours escape to the golf course like
I'll play by myself I'll play with actor
friends i'll play with anybody wants to
go knock the ball around a little bit i
used to get really into it when i was a
kid and really competitive and
frustrated if i wasn't playing well now
I just appreciate being able to be out
of the office and on the golf course for
four hours or so so I do that if I have
a weekend when I'm not covering the film
or traveling I'll try and find some time
to get out there and should be outside
hanging out with friends that's been a
real kind of life saver and as things
have got more stressful in my career
well I'm curious too what's the typical
day like for you because you said that
you you really have a lot of know Dave
is really the same yeah what sort of the
I mean that's honestly that's what
something's been really exciting for me
covering movies the last ten years or so
is that there isn't really a typical day
every movie has a different life in
terms of how they roll out to the public
and as somebody works in the press you
know we're instrumental in that process
so sometimes you see you have to go see
a movie really early before it comes out
sometimes you see a film at midnight
that you know the day it's released
sometimes you're doing interviews a
month in advance three months in advance
sometimes you're doing in a week before
so every day is really different today
came into the office for a few hours
it's voice-overs for a set visit piece
I'd done but a movie called rush with
Olivia Wilde and did some voiceovers
hang out with you guys for a little bit
make some phone calls then I want to go
interview everybody from Tyrone was love
and we go see Bill Cosby do stand-up
tonight the beverly hills hotel is very
excited about that so that's an awesome
day like every I try and build days that
keep me productive keep me interacting
with a lot of different people but every
day is different you know
depends on on the season summer movie
season now so there's a lot of stuff
rolling out so it keeps us busy usually
you know in March or April things are a
little slower but but yeah every every
day is different which is really what i
love about the job did you know from a
young age that you would never be that
40 hour week guys yeah i mean i saw
those my dad you know my dad would go to
movies at you know a night and he'd have
shoot he'd be on the early news cast at
you know 530 or something on friday
mornings and you know you'd have to
sometimes occasionally to work a weekend
or whatever it was that i just saw we
saw his schedule kind of moving around
and was never just go to work at nine
and come home at seven it was every day
was different and I kind of I didn't
know I was gonna end up doing something
very similar to him but I knew that I
would want to be kind of on the go and
try and make a life for myself where I
didn't have that traditional work
environment so what's trying to figure
to have it still
you